ronzheimer ist jetzt zwei monate später
wieder genau dort
schon guten morgen paul ronzheimer jetzt
also in der ost ukraine in dieser region
nehmen uns mit dorthin stehen diese
häuser noch gibt es diese dörfer noch
sind die russisch und wie geht's
ludmilla
[Applaus]
tatsächlich bin ich von diesem ort wo
ich gerade stehe
fluchtartig kann man sagen am 24 februar
richtung kiew aufgebrochen das war der
moment als die sirenen auch hier los
ging auch gestern nacht wollen wieder
sirenen zu hören und als ich hier
aufgebrochen bin von diesem ort und
richtung kiew gefahren bin da hätte ich
nie gedacht dass ich wieder kommen
könnte und dieses dorf diese stadt das
konstantinov k noch unter ukrainischer
kontrolle wäre und tatsächlich auch
ludmilla die ein bisschen weiter lebt
nämlich gfk wir haben gestern bereits
telefonischen kontakt gehabt mit ihr sie
lebt noch und sie lebt auch noch dort
und das obwohl diese stadt so heftig
unter beschuss geraten ist dort sollen
sogar phosphorbomben eingesetzt worden
sein wir haben sie am telefon gehabt sie
hat gesagt wenn ihr heute bei mir
vorbeikommen wenn es irgendwie schafft
zu mir dann bringt mir bitte
schmerzmittel mit denn sie hat
verletzungen erlitten aber es gibt nicht
mehr genügend medikamente dort das ist
ludmilla die wir so häufig besucht haben
in den vergangenen jahren nicht nur im
februar sondern in den jahren zuvor
immer wieder als wir hier aus der ost
ukraine berichtet haben hier in dieser
region kam patricia war ja die
sogenannte front die acht jahre ging und
man hätte erwartet oder wir haben das so
erwartet dass diese dörfer und städte
überrannt würden wenn dieser krieg
beginnt deswegen sind wir damals auch
erst mal richtung kiew wo sich das ganze
konzentrierte und jetzt hier gestern
nacht haben wir schüsse gehört gestern
nacht haben wir sirenen gehört die ganze
nacht hier eine andere sirene die klingt
anders als in kiew sie hält länger an
ist noch penetranter lauter als das was
wir kannten aus der hauptstadt und wir
gehen davon aus dass der angriff auch
weiter richtung concertino erfolgt in
den nächsten tagen wochen tatsächlich
sind die russen vorgerückt als anderer
ort an dem wir uns aufgehalten haben
wo wir auch eine familie besucht haben
im februar diese familie ist
mittlerweile werk geflüchtet in die
hauptstadt die hatten vier kinder ein
junges baby als dieser krieg begann sind
sie doch dort geblieben und jetzt weg
tatsächlich ist es so dass hier im
donbass die angst vieler menschen groß
ist dass die russen hier diese dörfer
diese städte in den nächsten tagen
wochen überrennen könnten sie haben
lände gewinne gemacht in den vergangenen
tag sagt paul ronzheimer aus dem don was
dort wo er einen stunden vor dem
kriegsbeginn war und dorthin ist er
jetzt auch wieder zurückgekehrt in
besonders umkämpft jetzt auch wieder
diese region lasst uns einmal gemeinsam
auf das blicken was vladimir putin jetzt
sagt er spricht eine drohung aus eine
sehr konkrete drohung richtung westen
[Musik]
wenn irgendwer von außerhalb sich dem
die laufenden ereignisse einmischt und
so eine strategische gefahr für uns
schafft muss er mit einer blitzschnellen
antwort rechnen wir haben dafür alle
instrumente und wir werden nicht planen
hier werden sie anwenden wenn es nötig
ist und ich will dass alle das wissen
weiterhin als zugeschaltet aus dem
damals in der ukraine
paul meint putin mit diesen worten auch
ganz konkret deutschland
er würde jeden fall der welt drohen evtl
panik machen er will angst machen
patricia und das interessante an seinen
worten finde ich eigentlich dass ich
davon ausgehe dass er diese worte die er
jetzt an die gesamte öffentlichkeit
richtet zuvor in den telefonaten mit
olaf scholz zum beispiel geäußert hat
und dass das eine erklärung dafür ist
warum zb deutschland was
panzerlieferungen so vorsichtig war das
erklärt sich für mich zumindest jetzt
wenn ich das höre was wladimir putin
dort sagt diese spekulation gab es schon
länger dass er staatschefs wie olaf
scholz eben am telefon direkt gedroht
hat mit konsequenzen und jetzt sieht er
sogar deutschland schwenkt um sogar
deutschland hilft er hört gleichzeitig
wie groß die hilfe der amerikaner ist
und er ist natürlich auch besorgt über
seine eigenen kriegsziele denn auch wenn
er hier vorankommt ist es so dass er bis
zum 9 mai also am tag der kapitulation
von nazi-deutschland dass er bis dahin
ein sieg wollte wie immer der auch
aussieht und der ist zumindest zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht so groß
wie er sich ihnen vielleicht vorgestellt
hat und dafür macht der vor allem die
waffenlieferung das teilen von
geheimdiensterkenntnissen
verantwortlich deswegen jetzt auch diese
ganz offene drohung was könnte er damit
meinen er könnte damit meinen das ist
auf waffenlieferungen schläge anschläge
gibt er könnte damit aber auch angriffe
auf andere staaten meinen das ist lässt
er ganz bewusst offen man muss auch
sagen dass in seinem propaganda
fernsehen in den vergangenen tagen sich
noch einmal die sprache verschärft hat
dort ist von einem dritten weltkrieg die
rede von einem drohenden dritten
weltkrieg der wahrscheinlicher würde
also man versucht zumindest dort die
drohkulisse immer weiter aufzubauen und
spricht gerade die putin propaganda an
mitten in diese propaganda platz sein
video das per youtube jetzt um die welt
geht von einem der sich abgesetzt hat
von putin aus russland einem mächtigen
mann nämlich von ihm hier ich konnte es
nicht länger ertragen länger in russland
zu bleiben sagt egal wo lobinzew er war
der vizepräsident der staatlichen
russischen gazprom bank ernährt russland
nicht nur verlassen er ist in die
ukraine gegangen um dort zu kämpfen
er sagt meine rückkehr ist ein akt der
buße ich möchte mich von meiner
russischen vergangenheit reinwaschen ich
werde bis zum sieg in der ukraine
bleiben das sagt der mann der in der
ukraine in der region sumi geboren ist
seine millionen aber und in russland
machte sein leben dort verbrachte ein
prominenter mann in russland der sich
jetzt ganz deutlich von putin abwendet
und ganz deutlich auch davon von dingen
spricht die in russland oder sprach als
strafe stehen von krieg spricht sagt ich
kann das nicht ertragen
wie sehr trifft so etwas glaubst du paul
vladimir putin
ich glaube wladimir putin wird ihnen auf
jeden fall auf der liste derjenigen
ergänzt haben die ja tot sehen möchte
das ganz sicher denn für wladimir putin
sind menschen wie er verräter und
auf die macht russland oder hat muss
dann schon immer jagd gemacht
gleichzeitig versucht die ukraine und
hofft natürlich die ukraine dass es mehr
solcher menschen die man hatte auch am
anfang des krieges gehofft dass der
widerstand größer würde wir erinnern uns
es gab am anfang des krieges ein
bisschen demonstrationen im sankt
petersburg vor allem die wurden dann
niedergeknüppelt aber am ende bekommt
man hier zumindest in der ukraine doch
das gefühl dass die mehrheit der
russischen bevölkerung irgendwie hinter
putin steht hinter diesen krieg steht
auch diese absurde schlimme propaganda
glaublich bekommen dass hier auch immer
mit wenn meine ukrainischen freunde noch
mit menschen telefonieren die sie in
russland kennen und die dann ganz offen
zu ihnen sagen aber ihr seid doch da von
nazis umgeben ihr habt eine nazi
regierung also daran sehe ich immer
wieder wie sehr diese propaganda
wirklich angekommen ist auch im
russischen volk mit selbst mit
prominenten wie vitali klitschko der mir
berichtet wenn er kontakte dort nach
russland hat und hört dass er dann auch
das zu hören bekommt also alte freunde
von ihm das zieht sich quer durch die
gesellschaft deswegen ist so ein schritt
eines mannes so ja eine nachricht eine
große nachrichten natürlich in der
ukraine und man hofft dass dadurch mehr
folgt paul nun bist du also dass da eine
geschichte heute nach zwei monaten
zurückgekehrt an die stelle die duh
fluchtartig verlassen hast am
23 und 24 februar dort in der ost
ukraine als dann die russische invasion
tatsächlich kam an diese orte bist du
jetzt zurückgekehrt nach etwas mehr als
zwei monaten also und hast uns gerade so
emotional berichte von ludmilla die wir
hier nochmal im bild sehen von damals
mit der du jetzt wieder telefoniert hat
sie lebt dort sie ist da sie hat das
geschafft über diese zwei monate ihr
dorf ist nicht in russischen händen du
hast berichtet dass sie und
schmerzmittel gebeten hat deswegen noch
mal zum schluss die frage glaubst du
kannst das organisieren heute glaubst du
du wirst dorthin kommen zu ihr wirst dir
irgendwas bringen können hier irgendwie
helfen können
wir versuchen zu ludmilla heute zu
kommen tatsächlich ist es gar nicht so
einfach leben zu finden keine hier noch
offen haben das so genannte hotel in dem
wir damals waren da sind bretter vor die
fenster gehämmert worden auch aus sorge
wir sind da die einzigen gäste
das wurde dann für uns so halb extra
aufgeschlossen es gibt hier keine
restaurants keinen leben die wirklich
auf haben wir müssen erst mal schauen ob
für eine farm ist sie eine apotheke
finden und diese schmerzmittel finden
für sie aber dann versuchen wir dorthin
zu kommen nur diese wege sind natürlich
gefährlich man muss sich dort genau
vorbereiten denn manche fk dass diese
stadt wo laut müller aus hardy ist
heftig umkämpft sie wohnt dort direkt
fast kann man sagen an der front
deswegen sind auch in den vergangenen
jahren schon so viel raketen bei ihrem
garten runtergerechnet deswegen ist es
fast ein wunder dass sie immer noch lebt
und diese stadt droht ganz besonders in
die hand russische soldaten zu fahren
paul ronzheimer im donbass vielen
herzlichen dank der paul für deinen
schilder untergehen